et l'intérêt de 6000 au mètre carré qui
s'autoalimente ichou
aucune
encore en corse en corse
plus ou moins monsieur le maire nous
sommes perdus
clé tout le temps et continentaux ils
sont perdus
en fait le problème c'est qu'on n'arrive
pas à lire les panneaux 1
les panneaux c'est comme des balances et
nous on aime pas et valence
on voudrait juste avant ce billet nous
indiquer la route les deux routes et
yvan celle là c'est plus court mais
c'est plus long et celle là c'est plus
long mais c'est plus qu'on est d'accord
c'est encore plus boxer de photos
bonjour c'est vous qui allez construire
la wii le problème si vous construisez
sais que vous allez me gâcher la vue ça
commence bien
[Musique]